hey Spenny people this is a tutorial on
standard throws - behind the head
catches for point the behind the head
catch is a super functional skill that
works across props for funsies and flow
and it's easier than it looks so let's
get started the toss is going into the
behind the head catch can be thought of
as a combination of two things
standard underhand toss on the wall
plane and a downward stall behind the
head this is also sometimes called it's
been transferred
make sure that your playing going into
the toss is flat and following the wall
plane only with a little bit of change
step 2 bring it behind your body you can
practice with your native or non-native
hand notice that when the poi is caught
into the downward stall the thumb of the
receiving hand is pointing down the
catching hand awaits behind the head
with the thumb downward meanwhile the
incoming poi will have that hand and
palm to fingertip as its target oh look
at that nice big comfy target
as of many things the best way to learn
this catch is with repetition start
tossing and remember to drill both sides
when you start to get comfortable and
explore the different body spaces you
can toss from icon there's a non-native
leg near the native leg and back and
underneath the armpit just to name a few
a really good drill is tossing from each
of the body spaces without skipping a
beat imagery
as your comfort grouse try drills like
this one we have both deploy and spin in
same time opposite direction and then
toss from each body space behind the
head one beat in between let's look at
it again from behind tossing from the
front tossing from under non-native leg
under native leg and under the armpit
you